ja die tat selber soll sich in der nacht
zum frühen morgen zwischen 33 und 37 auf
seinem anwesen in grünau im almtal
abgespielt haben
woher also diese wüsten drohungen
ausgestoßen haben soll die polizei der
polizeiposten in scharnstein hat davon
dann am vormittag erfahren die
staatsanwaltschaft hat dann sozusagen
einfach die schon bekannten verfahren
gegen den ins zusammengelegt die letzten
einträge in seiner stammt mir aus mitte
juli
diese fälle allein hätten noch nicht
gereicht um eine haftanordnung zu
erreichen jetzt hat aber auch der
richter in wels gesagt es reicht jetzt
es langt und hat also bestimmt dass man
ins als august auf seinem jagdschloss
gelände in einem sperrgebiet festnimmt
daraufhin haben als der polizei
polizisten sein anwesen gegen 17 uhr am
abend um stellt ihnen dann abgeführt und
seit gestern abend und zur stunde noch
lautet jetzt die neue wenig
herrschaftliche anschrift des prinzen
justizanstalt wels
vielen dank für diese aktuellen
eindrücke als allererstes hat über die
festnahme die kronen zeitung aus
österreich bericht und genau deswegen
möchte ich darüber jetzt sprechen mit
christoph gantner von der grundsicherung
guten tag sagen sie uns wie genervt ist
in österreich jetzt von dem
welfenprinzen wie genervt ist die
polizei auch dass sie so oft jetzt
einschreiten müssen der bevölkerung ist
es egal es ist ein älterer herr der
offensichtlich etwas verhaltensauffällig
ist für die polizei sieht die sache
schon sehr viel anders aus weil ja ernst
august nach den einsätzen jedes mal
behauptet hatte übergriffe gegeben und
zwar nicht von ihm auf die polizei nicht
von immer auf die polizei sondern von
der polizei als ihnen
dieses mal sind die polizisten dann mit
body camps ausgerückt als sie gestern
abend oder nachmittag dann das jagdhaus
umstellt haben warum genau
die bode games sind einfach dafür
gedacht dass man einsätze aufnimmt und
in dem konkreten fall hat sich das
soeben als auch als sinnvoll erwiesen
weil die exekutive möchte sich natürlich
auch absichern und kann das beweisen wie
es wirklich abgelaufen ist es steht in
grünau im almtal ein kleiner ort da
spricht man ja wahrscheinlich trotzdem
sehr viel auch über den prinzen der
immer wieder auffällig wird lacht man
oder schimpft man eher über ihnen
offizier immer nur gesagt dass er sehr
beliebt ist er ist doch als sehr
großzügiger spender bei den für die
vereine bekannt man muss aber auch dazu
sagen es ist ein sehr enges kleines
gebiet stylen mit sehr viel wald und
dieser wald gehörte imprints prinzen
ernst august also verhält sich hier sehr
zurück mehr nachrichten breaking news
nur bei bet schaue ich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren